in recent years we have made important
progress toward the final conquest of
tuberculosis to a great extent aided by
newer and better hospitals and
sanatorius and naturally as every health
officer knows such a hospital or
sanatorium is the best place to treat
tuberculosis when it is possible
with our elaborate equipment constant
and thorough supervision and complete
facilities these hospitals help patients
to conquer their disease
they give more effective help because
they can apply definite principles of
isolation treatment education and
rehabilitation
every nurse has had some glimpse of
these principles at work during her
professional training and experience the
first element of tuberculosis care is
the understanding between doctor and
nurse this understanding is vital to
successful collaboration in the care of
the patient
it is also vital to the relationship of
the nurse to the patient and family
always the doctor is responsible for
making the diagnosis the doctor also
orders medication and plans treatment
the nurse is responsible for
administering the doctor's plan she
shares with the doctor responsibility
for teaching patients and family
seldom can be equal in any home the
effectiveness of hospital care but we
can apply a number of the same definite
principles which are familiar elements
in contagious disease nursing technique
in the scenes which follow you'll see a
typical family in a typical case for the
public health nursing compared to
hospital nursing there are both
similarities and differences in this
case from the time the doctor in charge
calls upon the public health nurse miss
abbott this is dr cannell i have another
patient for you
the name is evan
he has a wife
and has two children
the involvement
is bilateral
the sputum is positive
the family will need your usual
instruction
will you meet me there at 11 please 11
o'clock
yes
yes i know
i'll see you there doctor
like the nurse in the hospital this
public health nurse will follow the
doctor's orders for treatment but she
must also pass on the responsibility for
daily care to the family following the
doctor's orders she will help him to
explain the treatment of the family and
will teach some responsible member to
follow out the routine of care required
for the patient's welfare and for their
own safety you will see brief examples
of teaching by this nurse keep in mind
as you watch them that she has carried
over to public health service from her
hospital training
five proven elements of teaching which
you will see are used
here they are
principles of teaching that are applied
in all effective education first
good hospital teaching is affirmative
the teacher
must make far less use of don't
than of do
second
the item to be taught must be stated
clearly in a few simple words
keep instruction short
third
the teacher must demonstrate what she
has described
fourth
the learner must demonstrate that he
fully understands
the instructions
finally use printed material
as a reminder of your teaching get it
from your health department or
tuberculosis association
material can never take the place of
person-to-person teaching any more than
a short motion picture can teach
complete home nursing but it can help
make your teaching more effective by
crystallizing the details of treatment
but when it comes to such a problem as
the patient's morale printed material is
of little use that factor must be
governed only by the human approach
this element of morale is so important
that even before teaching this family
the routine of care and before showing
the patient how to protect his family
the nurse tries to establish the right
attitude in the patient's mind she
chooses her words and her approach
carefully explaining simply trying to
install the will to recover she makes it
clear that treatment is not just
something we do to the patient but
something to which he must contribute
the patient's morale is one of the
determining factors in his recovery and
it controls the extent of the protection
he gives the family with the
understanding and cooperation of the
patient the nurse's work will be more
successful she must make him believe it
is worthwhile to get well
the next treatment principle to be
transferred from hospital to home is
separation of the patient from the
community
this can best be done when we remove the
patient to a tuberculosis hospital or
sanatorium
in a well-conducted hospital
separation from the community is
combined with evidence that treatment is
conducted for the patient's own benefit
and protection
in the home we must apply whatever we
can of communicable disease nurturing
techniques when possible we try to
assign the patient to a single private
room in any case a separate bed is
essential and the patient must have
completely separate equipment as well
dishes linens and personal needs should
be kept apart the nurse explains this
affirmatively as routine medical
procedure without over emphasizing the
isolation of the patient she persuades
patient and family that separation will
protect the patient as well as protect
others from his bacilli she keeps a
safety zone as wide as possible
now she improvises visible barriers to
symbolize the privacy of her patient
even in a one-room dwelling naturally it
is important to protect others from the
tuberculosis bacilli which invades every
corner of the room these paratroopers
can carry tuberculosis from patient to
family
but their near relatives carry coals and
pneumonia from family to patient too
so a relative's cold can complicate your
patient's illness dangerously
after this is explained clearly to the
patient and family the nurse leaves this
printed reminder the public health nurse
has been hailed as a shoe leather
epidemiologist her teaching about
infection provides a natural
introduction to this part of her service
checking the patient's contacts here is
a positive method of identifying all
contacts which has helped to find a lot
of tuberculosis
there
represented by the square you have the
patient
a circle for the white the line of
descent and the two children
shade the square for a known active case
put a question mark for each known
contact
does a patient have any brothers or
sisters
show them
and here's your carrier a sister who
died of tuberculosis
the system is simple
modify the basic idea and it'll fit any
family condition
it's an effective aid in finding cases
early enough to make treatment
successful
and now we come to our next factor of
treatment
cleanliness
simple cleanliness helps to fight
tuberculosis
we cannot duplicate in the home complete
hospital apparatus
but we can teach the value and
importance of cleanliness
case is so primitive that soap and water
cannot be used as a supplement to soap
and water explain the cleansing
properties of sunlight affirmatively to
the family
teach the family that cleanliness helps
to protect everyone that they as well as
the patient guard themselves by
practicing cleanliness make the family
understand how cleanliness particularly
with dishes and other objects used by
the patients is a fundamental necessity
and teach the patient too that his
cleanliness will protect the family he
must learn to do his part to prevent
further infection of himself and others
the use of disposable tissues must be
made perfectly clear to the patient the
whole family must understand how to
handle such contaminated material
this type of instruction shows very
plainly the steps in effective teaching
as they apply in the home care of
tuberculosis
watch now the application of these
elements as we explain the disposal of
contaminated tissues to the family
first
explanation
then
demonstration show the whole procedure
then you get participation by having a
procedure carried out for you
now explanation demonstration and
participation are repeated in stressing
a second point in the procedure that the
family must guard themselves to by
constant cleanliness here shown by
washing the hands thoroughly after
handling contaminated material
and finally now the printed reminder
covers both points in the procedure
we'll purposely delay the vital fifth
principle of treatment which is rest but
we need a foundation upon which rest
will be possible and effective
notice how the principles of treatment
form a pyramid
confidence in medical direction is
essential in all treatment
rest is a little more than a word until
we establish the opportunity of complete
separation
and privacy
a clean bed and a clean body
are great helps in relaxation and rest
remember
the family has never seen bed rest in a
tuberculosis hospital
you must explain it to them
bed rest means being washed and bathed
and shaved in bed
bed rest means too
being fed in bed not getting up for any
reason
and most important bed rest means a
recumbent position not sitting up until
the doctor prescribes that chain
finally bed rest means regular daily
intervals of complete relaxation rest
for both body and mind
the patient may shorten his illness by
giving hours each day to absolute bed
rest
and it is necessary to explain gently
firmly to the family and to friends that
listening to others is not rest
the next important item is nutrition not
only what to eat but the balance of
meals
talk in terms of a common sense menu
which can be purchased by the patient's
family with the funds available
the question of nutrition may well be
taken up in the instruction of the
second visit in a fresh sterile gown the
nurse teaches the family to avoid any
contamination of the food supply
in planning a diet assure the family
that the patient makes little real gain
by being stuck and that weight alone
does not mean recovery
show the family how to improvise a tray
and how to make the food on that tray
look attractive
the result will help to stimulate the
patient's appetite and his intake of the
right foods for his needs
yes even a meal that's good for you can
be appetizing
suitable recreation when medically
approved is an important factor in
inducing patients to accept treatment
whether in the hospital or in the home
your instruction to the family is not
complete
unless you yourself
have given some thought
and
provoke in the home some thought as to
what the patient may do for recreation
during his illness
especially when he becomes sputum
negative
now here is an example of hand work
learned from an occupational therapist
and talk to the patient under the
doctor's approval
as the patient continues to make
progress his reading time may be
gradually increased and now with his
recovery approaching the public health
nurse arranges for a conference doctor i
came to see if the patient is ready for
rehabilitation training mr bronson is
from the state agency yes he should be
ready to start on mr bronson's plan the
first of next month
figuring on three months training can we
put him on a job when it's completed
i believe we can count on that send him
in for a recheck regularly while he is
training
if all continues to go well the physical
demands you describe here will be well
within its tolerance thank you
yes here is our ultimate goal the final
reward for patient effort care and
thought
to get the patient back on his feet back
to a job suitable to his condition and
the future needs of his family to make
him a working contributing member of the
community
you may obtain printed material for the
instruction the patient of the family
from the agency that arranged the
showing of this film
make yourself familiar with all the
publications available from your local
tuberculosis association
you